this video is brought to you by
Squarespace whether you need a domain
website or online store make it with
Squarespace
hey wisecrack Jerrod here today we're
talking about an Amazon and she has
nothing to do with an endangered plant
species or free two-day shipping
Wonderwoman wasn't just the mega box
office hit of the summer the film and
its eponymous hero have become one of
20:17 biggest cultural icons and
surprise we have something to say about
it now some have called ares a pretty
lackluster villain but his conflict with
diana is pretty interesting compared to
most superhero villains who want to just
rule the world or rule the world or rule
Asgard or rule the universe
and part of what makes this Greek god
family drama so cool is that
Ares doesn't just blindly hate Diana
their clash over the nature and fate of
humanity is well pretty philosophical so
get ready to be lassoed by the truth in
this wisecrack edition on the philosophy
of Wonder Woman and cue the sirens one
of the central conflicts of Wonder Woman
is do humans deserve to be saved this
makes sense since the titular characters
from an island of warrior women who
exist solely to save humans from
destruction at the hand of Ares the God
of War but as it turns out when you've
lived in a tropical paradise with no
boys allowed for a couple millennia you
might decide that humans aren't really
worth the effort Zeus created men to be
just and wise strong and passionate that
was a story Diana much of Diana's
struggle is wrapped up in the question
of what it means to save people she
wavers between a sense of duty a sense
of caring and a moment of great a apathy
they don't deserve our help meanwhile
Ares is fully committed to the belief
that humans suck a fat bag of popsicles
and deserve not only abandonment but
also to die painfully via chemical
weapons Ares developed a weapon the
worst ever devised
Diana's big hero statement of the film
is in response to Ares has claimed that
she responds it's not about deserve it's
about what you believe
and we believe that line is confusing as
but instead of dismissing it as bad
writing and good old wisecracking in
fashion let's pull it apart now before
we get to Diana we have to understand
what she's responding to Ares is belief
that humans are worthless and can't have
nice things
Ares has claimed in the film has two
parts one that humans deserve to be
punished and two that they don't deserve
Diana's help right the first one is a
question of something called retributive
justice basically the theory that argues
that people who do bad things should go
to jail so what informs Aries is
retributive mission to destroy humanity
he believes that humans are by nature
evil selfish and capable of the
creator's harvest this is an
essentialist view of human nature that
humanity has inherent properties that
make them what they are
so people are doomed to be useless
[ __ ] forever so it makes sense why
you'd want to get rid of them
Ares his claim is bolstered by the some
of humanity's actions over the last
couple thousand years and that time
humans have done a lot they genocided a
bunch of people destroyed the
environment and made this Logan Paul guy
famous mankind stove as well from
they ruined it day by day so that's the
first part of Aries is claim now for the
second one one that is much more central
to Diana and the film's arc the question
of who deserves to be saved even if it's
from their own kind
this is distributive justice in Aries
calculation being saved from death is
not something that one is entitled to
it's something that is distributed based
on merit as shown by the actions of the
individual or in this case the actions
of the group spanning three plus
millennia this seems to be a pretty
common idea among immortals Diana's
mother Hippolyta tells her they do not
deserve you this all reflects one
popular approach to distributive justice
called desert theory which argues that
people deserve things jobs money awards
based on their actions rather than on
their needs or the benefit it would
bring to society
now although Diana stays generally
consistent in her desire to help
humanity the logic behind this choice
develops and changes throughout the film
and while we see people justifying their
actions with distributive or Richard
suit of frameworks Wonderwoman goes a
different route Diana is raised to
believe that the Amazons have a sacred
duty to stop Ares and defend the world
so when she sets out for Europe she's
not doing it because she believes humans
deserve anything it's because she has a
moral obligation to help this moral
obligation carries her through most of
the film even as she watches British
generals send soldiers to their death
and Germans taking villagers as slaves
but at some point she realizes that
people suck and it wasn't totally Ares
his fault that they were bayonetting
each other they can stop fighting back
why are they since her duty was to
defend the world from Ares and not CH
humans acting on their own accord she's
not really sure where her moral
obligations lie anymore
all of a sudden her mom's wise words
sound a whole lot wiser
she said the world of men did not
deserve you Dianna's faced with a crisis
of conscience she's no longer found by
duty and her knowledge of human
atrocities leader to the conclusion that
humans do not merit her help as a matter
of justice either although Diana makes
it less obvious than Ares does
she's also motivated by a kind of
essentialism let's call this the battle
of essential isms Ares says humans are
inherently evil Diana says they're
inherently good while Ares never
abandons his essentialism Diana does
when she discovers humans can be
dickbags all on their own we don't see
too much more of this philosophical
crisis but all is resolved by the time
she says denied the news at first it
might sound like she believes in the
love of Steve Trevor but that doesn't
make a ton of sense so let's give her a
little more credit than that it's only
at the end that it becomes clear to her
and to us why saving people is the right
thing to do what differentiates Diana at
the end from someone like Captain
America is that she realizes it's not
her duty to help people she just wants
to because she loves the [ __ ] out of
humanity even though that might sound
like a saccharine care-bear cop-out it's
not while she leaves behind the ideas of
duty and deserving Wonder Woman taps
into a totally different ethical
approach that's pretty unique in the
superhero genre terror ethics
care ethics focuses on the relationship
between the person who is caring for
someone and the person who is caring for
a good example a parent who loves their
child even if that child is terrible or
Logan Paul unlike most traditional
approaches to ethics care ethics rejects
universalize principles for how to make
judgments or how to act
everything is contextualized within the
given relationship however certain
practices are pretty important like
respect empathy and attention to the
needs of others sometimes these
relationships aren't equal footing but
not always Wonder Woman is not our equal
so it's more like a person caring for a
perfect puppy just like you're not born
with an obligation to care for a dog
Wonder Woman knowingly chooses to enter
a relationship of care with people who
will never be able to entirely
reciprocate and maybe don't deserve it
she isn't pursuing a defined goal other
than making the world a better place or
holding firm to certain universal
principles like
man's idea that killing is always wrong
or Captain America's belief in the
American Way as long as you forget that
whole hail Hydra thing she is responding
as needed to the needs of those she
cares for at the end of the film Diana's
relationship rejects a kind of
distributive or retributive justice and
instead she makes a choice to love them
but then I glimpsed the darkness that
lives within their light and learned
that inside every one of them there will
always be both and now I know but only
love can truly save the world
Diana's belief in love isn't a
meaningless platitude it's a declaration
of her commitment to a particular state
of mind an action that guides her
decisions as a hero this is clear in her
decision not to kill dr. Poisson despite
her being a war criminal and also really
creepy although it would be a bit of a
stretch to say that wonder woman enters
a relationship of care with Colonel
Mustard gasps just because she decides
not to throw a literal tank at her it's
indicative of Diana's change in mindset
this is visually paralleled by dr.
poisons masked flying off piece by piece
as the wind uncovers her true scarred
ugly self they say very obvious metaphor
and Diana recognizes the complex nature
and individual differences of humans
everything you say
but so much more even though by most
calculations doctor Poisson probably
deserves to die dianna rejects the
concept of deserving and by extension
rejects the desert theory of justice
that Aries is so fond of every superhero
has his or her or its reasons for
blowing stuff up and saving the day
Wonder Woman defines Diana's ethos of
care and solidifies her role in the
Justice League for many franchises to
come but it also draws out a frequent
theme in comics the worthiness of the
people saved
Gotham doesn't deserve Batman and
America doesn't deserve Steve Rogers
Wonder Woman raises a question that we
don't usually hear does humanity deserve
to be saved at all
and even if they don't should we save
them anyway thanks for watching you guys
peace looking to last up a beautiful
professional website to promote your
work Squarespace has got you covered
using the offer code wisecrack you can
head over to Squarespace today to get
10% off your first purchase with a
wealth of gorgeous designer templates on
an easy-to-use all-in-one platform
Squarespace makes it easy for you to
create an eye-catching fully functional
website for your art or business with
zero coding knowledge required check out
Squarespace comm for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your site go
to Squarespace comm slash wisecrack and
use the offer code wisecrack to save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
domain thanks to Squarespace for
sponsoring this video and thank you all
for watching remember to hit that
subscribe button and ring that Bell
catch y'all next time peace